No,
I'm,
I often talk to people who are trying to make a difficult life decision and they
are weighing out the costs and the benefits of making the life decisions.
You know,
and one of the things I always talk to them about is wait a second,
that's an incomplete analysis.
You have to weigh out the benefits and the costs of doing this and you have to
weigh out the costs and benefits of not doing that,
not doing it.
And that's not the same as the zero that you assume that you're starting with.
Right.
Because to not make a decision also has a cost.
And sometimes the cost of not making a decision is far worse than the cost of
making a decision,
even if the decision is risky.
And so one of the things you can derive from that,
and this is very useful I think,
is that
this is also I think why it's so useful to contemplate your mortality,
so to speak,
as you're screwed,
no matter what you do,
you know,
and that actually frees you is that you,
you,
you have power at the hay that has catastrophes.
And you have path B that has catastrophes and you don't get to have the no
catastrophe path,
but you get to pick which one.
And that's really something because if you know that there's terrible risk
associated with everything that you do and don't do,
then you can afford to take some risks because you're not,
you know,
and this is all within the arc metaphor.
I'm still making the case that despite the fact that your life is essentially
catastrophic,
you can,
you can make a covenant with the highest ideal and that will take you through it
the best way possible.
I'm,
I'm still making that case.
So,
so then you think,
okay,
well I'm trying to make this decision.
I'm going to go try to do something difficult and isn't that terrifying?
And then you think,
yeah,
but wait a minute.
What's really terrifying is not doing it.
And then you think about the cost of not doing it.
So in the future authoring program,
we have people do this,
a little meditative exercise,
which is,
okay,
just think about your insufficiencies by your own definition,
right?
The way that you don't do what you know you should do about the things that you
do that you shouldn't do,
that you know you shouldn't do beyond a shadow of a doubt,
right?
There's some things like that and that that's bad habits and poor aim and all of
the resentment and hatred and aggression and unresolved conflicts and all those
things that are dementing you and warping you and then think,
okay,
those things get the upper hand man,
they get the upper hand and they take you the worst possible place you could go
in the next three to five years.
What exactly does that look like?
And so you sketch all that out and you think,
hey,
I don't want to go there.
And so the next time that a temptation comes up,
you think,
well,
it'd be a lot better for me if I didn't succumb to this temptation.
It's like,
that's kind of weak.
You'd look a little better if you didn't eat like a cheesecake a day or
something like that.
You know,
that's,
that's something,
but it's not the same as,
um,
I'm going to have diabetes and I'm going to lose my damn leg and in,
in five years if I don't get my eating under control.
That's motivating.
And so then the temptation comes along and you think,
oh,
how about no,
seriously?
How about,
no,
not just because a higher good would be obtained if I avoided it,
but because of a terrible catastrophe would be averted if I didn't.